hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar validation of clinical
LC ms/ms methods what you need to know I
am Judy Oracle lab routes and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and is made
possible by an open educational grant
from Agilent Agilent has had no input in
the selection of speakers content or
mode of presentation let's get started
you can post questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Deborah French
PhD the assistant director of chemistry
and director of mass spectrometry at the
University of California San Francisco
UCSF clinical laboratories dr. French
received a PhD in biochemistry from the
University of Strathclyde in Glasgow
Scotland she completed a
pharmacogenomics postdoctoral fellowship
at st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
in Memphis Tennessee and then completed
a clinical chemistry postdoctoral
fellowship at UCSF with Allen Wu in her
current role dr. French develops and
validates mass spectrometry assays for
steroid hormones therapeutic drug
monitoring and toxicology
she teaches Clinical Laboratory
scientists and residents about clinical
chemistry and mass spectrometry and
oversees the running of the chemistry
section with the director of chemistry
dr. French also holds a faculty
appointment as an associate clinical
professor in the Department of
Laboratory Medicine at UCSF dr. French
will now begin her presentation thank
you for the introduction and for the
invitation and to give this webinar so I
just quickly give you some financial
disclosure information and I have
received an honorarium and expenses from
a few places and I received my salary
from UCSF but none of that's applicable
for today's webinar so after this
presentation you should be able to
hopefully write the validation plan and
pre validation recommendations discuss
best practices and solutions for
determining common validation parameters
and also write a validation summary and
establish some aspect data review and
reporting criteria
but just to give you an overview of what
I'm going to talk about today we're
going to cover what method validation is
and why we should validate our methods
will quickly cover some available
resources and then we'll go into pre
validation is and then the majority of
the presentation will be on the method
validation parameter we'll talk about
post validation monitoring and then I'll
give you some advice from someone who's
probably done at the wrong way more time
than she'd care to mention
as method validation it's an objective
process that determines that your mass
spec method meets the requirements for
its intended purpose through laboratory
studies
imagine that you're performing studies
in your lab over over a given period of
time
you want to make sure that your mass
spec method
is robust enough so that every time you
run the sample it's going to give you
the right results and it is reproducible
and that analyte is stable and the
conditions that you're likely to
encounter during normal routine analysis
the way the lab does this is by carrying
out experiments that address specific
analytical variables over a period of
time under conditions that mimic
everyday use in the laboratory you can
kind of think about method validation as
stress testing your mass spec method
things to remember are that all methods
have error so it could be random error
systematic error you can have issues
with selectivity the goal of your method
validation is to define the nature and
the magnitude of this error
so why should we validate our asses
regulatory environments you are required
to validate your method and these
requirements may vary depending upon
exactly what function your laboratory
has it's also based practice to validate
your method and the reason for this is
that you really want to ensure that your
method is accurate reproducible and
robust
so that it doesn't it's not affected by
small variations and things like new
mobile phase or chromatography columns
in room temperature fluctuations or if a
different technologist runs the
instrument Thank You Vera if you're
participating in some kind of study over
time where a patient is being monitored
for example you want to know that any
change in results is due to some
clinical reason and not because of your
method
we going to validate well today we're
going to discuss the validation of drug
X you can see a diagram of it here
so one thing to remember is that you are
not alone there are resources out there
and some of them are listed on this
slide
your cap inspectors lab the checklist
for chemistry and toxicology has some
guidance regarding method validation
that is general for all methods but
there's also some specific guidance for
LCN from a spec
the clinical laboratory standards
institute or clsi has an approved
guideline c62 that really delve deep
into mass spect method validation
there's also other guidance out there
such as the FDA guidance the EMM a
guidance and the European Union
directive that all discuss validation of
vile analytical methods you can also
look on PubMed for published papers to
see how other people have done
validations but one thing to note is
that potentially they're not held to the
same high standards that you're held to
so you have to be careful that you
definitely do what you need to
accomplish don't just rely on papers
so if it's your first method validation
you can always ask colleagues that run
MassPike methods we don't buy I promise
you can also use consultants and I've
never done that but it's definitely
something to consider if you and don't
have a lot of time or experience and to
dedicate to method development on
validation
so one thing that I would definitely
recommend is that before you start your
validation that you establish the
acceptability criteria for each
component
and you can find
Angell acceptability criteria our
guidance on acceptability criteria
through regulatory requirements and this
could be national or state dependent and
you can also use criteria that's noted
in the guidance documents I mentioned
earlier from clsi the FDA and the EMEA
if you're measuring an endogenous
finally you can also base your criteria
on biological variation and the Westgard
website at the bottom of this slide
documents biological variation and also
includes desirable specification for
precision and accuracy of the
measurements for each analyte
so when you got to this point you should
have your LC method your mass spec
method and your sample preparation
method or ready to go they should all be
sort of suits
so pre validation testing you can kind
of think about it as a mini validation
so it's smaller scale than a full
validation and the point of it really is
to help weed out issues before you
embark on a full validation
if the data from the prevalent looks
good then you can go into school
validation which includes determination
of a bunch of different parameters that
are listed on the slide and again as I
mentioned these documents and the bottom
of the slide are very good guidance
datian testing it essentially overlaps
with method development so you develop
your method and then you run some
samples to test it and if it doesn't
perform the way that you wanted it to
perform you can go back to method
development and tweak your methods so
that can be the chromatography method or
the sample preparation method depending
on what you need when you're at this
point you need some kind of blank matrix
so a matrix that does not contain your
analyte or analytes of interest and
that's because we're going to do some
spiking studies and also at this point I
usually prepare my own calibrators and
even if I'm going to purchase
calibrators later I would prepare some
just for some pre validation testing and
you need a blank matrix for that so the
acceptability criteria for a blank
matrix is that it should have no peak or
if it does have a peak the peak area
should be less than 20% of the analytes
lower limit of quantitation and less
than 5% of the internal standard peak in
the scan comes from the CLS I see 62
gatling now as you can imagine this can
be challenging if you're analyzing an
endogenous compounds and you can buy
stripped matrix in but it could be very
different from the your native matrix
for example serum or plasma and so it is
recommended that you should test as many
lots of the stripped matrix as possible
because variation is likely however
that's obviously cost prohibitive
another option is to use some kind of
surrogate matrix for example phosphate
buffered saline with albumin or water
but one thing to note is that if you are
going to make calibrators for example in
a non normal matrix or are known in
human matrix that there could be bias
introduced because of matrix differences
because as we'll see later the matrix
and can run definitely in the mass spec
and so a good way to do this is to check
the slope of the calibration curve
prepared in different materials or to
check that your calibrators am have okay
concentrations verified by the certified
reference material if it's available
you could run in human samples or
proficiency samples just to check that
your calibrators are accurate and that
there is no measurement by
so some of the prevail adacia
experiments I would recommend are shown
on this slide so in order to determine
if your method is linear you could run a
calibration curve and make sure that you
can in its what the method is linear up
to the concentration that you would like
to achieve in order to check accuracy
you could run a reference material if
it's available one thing to know is I
would run human samples as soon as
possible your method can look great when
you're just spiking aim your analyte
into matrix or in if you're using just
standards but then you run human samples
and you see all kinds of different Peaks
or interferences so I would run them as
soon as possible because then you can go
back to the drawing board and
potentially change your chromatography
to make your method better I would test
the imprecision of your method you can
use quality control materials to test
within run and between run and precision
it's also a good idea to check your
lower limit of quantitation to see if
you're getting the sensitivity that you
need and we can do this looking at the
precision of the measurements or
signal-to-noise and we'll get to all of
these later it's also a good idea to
test your method for matrix effect and
for extraction recovery and then it's
also good to test known interferences
for example if you want to measure
testosterone DHEA has the same mass so
you want to make sure that you can
measure testosterone and DHE
independently
so now we're going to talk about so
validation so for pre validation you
would probably just do fewer studies so
whatever I'm going to say for validation
going forward for pre validation you can
do sort of a limited version of fill
validation so CLIA has requirements for
laboratory-developed tests which most
mass spec methods are and these
requirements are that you should
determine accuracy and precision
analytical sensitivity and specificity
the reports will range reference
interval you also should determine your
test system calibration and control
procedures and you also have to document
all your activities
the first thing I would recommend is to
actually rate a validation plan in this
plan it's good to document all your
supplies that you're going to use the
reagents your quality control material
your calibrators and it's a good idea to
have a procedure written at this point
although you know remember your
validation you can also stop your
validation if it doesn't look good and
go back to the method development part
and then start your validation again so
you can tweak these things
it's good to have a the samples that you
want to run any proficiency testing
samples that you have and your primary
standards because again we're going to
do some spiking studies so you'll need
your a pure standards of your analytes
and then the internal standards that
you're going to use it's a good idea to
include the experimental details so how
many samples you're going to run how
many times you're going to run them and
over how many days things like that and
again you also want to define the
acceptance criteria
so on the slide is a suggested order of
experiments of course you can do in the
experiments in whatever order that you
want but it's definitely a good idea and
to run some of these things early on so
again I would run make sure your
linearity is good your lower limit of
quantitation I would say accuracy fairly
early on and definitely run some human
samples or the samples that you're going
to be running once you go live with your
method and you should think very
carefully about each one that you do to
maximize the amount of information that
you're getting from these runs so for
example we usually use our quality
control materials for the imprecision
studies and so you would basically run
your quality control material with every
run anyway you would also have your
calibrators so you can look at linearity
and then usually what I would do is is
add in the lower limit of quantitation
sample every run to so that you're just
optimizing the information it's also a
good idea to think about stability
fairly early on for example if you do a
run and then the samples are already
extracted then you can potentially put
them in the refrigerator or the freezer
and then run them after a week or a
month to see if the samples are still
stable
so now we're going to drill down and
look at each parameter individually
we're going to talk about accuracy
accuracy is the evaluation of agreement
between LC ms/ms test results and the
true value
there are guidelines and that have
acceptability criteria and a guide of
how you should perform accuracy
experiments and so the FDA and says that
you should analyze control material of a
known concentration and the
acceptability criterias and precision of
less than 15 less than or equal to 15
percent and a bias of less than equal to
15 percent
the clsi also has guidelines or for ep9
they suggest comparison with a higher
order reference method using a minimum
of 40 samples which are preferably human
especially if that's what your mass spec
method is going to be running normally
however there's not a reference method
available for all analytes and so that's
not always possible EP 15 suggests that
you analyze reference materials and
three to five different runs with each
sample measured and duplicate and again
there's no certified reference material
available for all analytes and so that's
not always possible either the c62 came
up with some different approaches to
assessing accuracy the best practice is
really to validate the trueness of your
method using a reference of higher-order
that's listed by the Joint Committee for
traceability and laboratory medicine so
best practice is to do a method
comparison with your method versus a JC
TLM approved reference measurement
procedure again however there's not one
of these available for every analyte
they also suggest you use matrix
appropriate certified reference
materials but again that's not always
available for every an align a third
option is to do spike in recovery
studies if the reference measurement
procedure or the certified reference
material is not available so one thing
to note with spike in recovery studies
is that it's a good idea to do it
blended so if you're going to have
somebody in your lab make the samples
ups or spiking the samples then I would
have someone different in the lab run
the actual samples and so that you're
running them in a blinded fashion so you
can compare the spite value with the
measured value
approaches are to use accuracy based
proficiency testing samples to check the
accuracy of your method again however
the null is available for every analyte
and finally an approach is to use a
method comparison with another lab using
shared samples and this is pretty much
normally what we would do in our
laboratory and so one thing to know is
that you should use samples as close to
those that will be routinely measured
using your mass spec method so if you're
going to run serum use serum if you're
going to use plasma plasma urine urine
and obviously you want to do this for
each analyte that you're measuring to
it's recommended that you use a minimum
of 40 samples that cover the analytical
measurement range all of your methods
and that these samples should be run in
at least five different days if you're
comparing to other methods
so this is just an example here we you
measured or drugged eggs with our method
and then in a competitor method with 66
a patient samples and as you can see the
correlation coefficient was 0.98 96 and
the slope of the line was one point zero
six eight so that indicates that we have
a little bit of a positive bias in our
method if we then look on the right hand
side we can see the percent bias port
and I you can kind of visualize easier
here that there is definitely a positive
bias so if we take an average of the
bias of all the samples we come up with
a mean percent by values of six percent
between us and the comparator method and
so I said earlier you should set your
acceptability criteria ahead of time the
problem when you do something like this
is that if you're not comparing to a
reference measurement procedure or a
certified reference material then you
actually don't know who's right and so
in this case I would say I mean bias of
six percent between us and the
comparator method would be acceptable
so next we're going to talk about
imprecision
and precision is the evaluation of
agreement between repeated analysis of
the same sample in a method validation
we are going to determine our within run
imprecision in other words taking the
same sample extracting it multiple times
on running it within the same analytical
batch we're also going to determine
between run and precision which is
extracting samples or different batches
on different days
so the samples you should use for
precision studies again should be matrix
match to what you're going to normally
use when you're running your mass spec
methods so and again then you need to
have imprecision studies for each
analyte and for each matrix that you're
going to be using
we usually carry out precision and
precision studies using our quality
control sample in that we'll be using in
our everyday analysis well that way you
can use the seam between one precision
data to set your acceptable range for
your QC sample
and it's also possible for you to make
your own so you can make a falls of
matrix match samples or you can
obviously also buy in material in order
to do these studies and the clsi
documents that are helpful are listed at
the bottom of this slide
right Iria for within run and precision
it's recommended that you run a minimum
of two different concentrations with ten
replicants and one run or one batch and
the CV should be less than 15%
for between one and precision again you
should run a minimum of two different
concentrations with a minimum of twenty
replicates preferably over 20 days and
again the CV should be less than 15
percent
so for quantitative mass effect methods
we usually always have three levels of
juicy material in our laboratory and so
we do precision studies with the three
different concentrations
this is just an example of the data that
we obtain from our drug eggs validation
so on the left hand side you can see the
with n1 and precision so this was 10 in
different extracted in 10 different
extractions from the same sample run and
one mana listicle badge and the mean
that we go was twelve point four six
nine events per mil with the CV of 2.8%
so that would be acceptable based on our
criteria of less than 15% on the right
hand side you can see the data from
there between 1m precision and this was
M 28 different analytical runs aim of
the same sample extracted each time and
the mean that we got here was eleven
point eight six nanograms per mil in
with a cv of 5.5 percent so again and
that would be deemed acceptable based on
our criteria
now we're going to talk about
sensitivity so the sensitivity of your
method is depicted by the lower limit of
quantitation or loq and this is the
lowest concentration that can be
reproducibly measured we can determine
our sensitivity by and precision with
the acceptability criteria of being less
than 20% in CV and this is based on
using 20 matrix mass matrix matched
replicates over 20 days you can also
determine your sensitivity by
signal-to-noise ratio and we'll get to
what that is in a second but it's
recommended that your signal-to-noise
ratio should be greater than 20 to 1 at
the lower limit of quantitation with ten
to one being the minimum signal-to-noise
ratio that's acceptable and you have to
also be remind that your iron ratios
still have to pass and we're going to
come to iron ratios a later on in the
talk um and some of the guidelines are
helpful can be seen at the bottom of
this slide
so often what I'm going to do if I'm
trying to determine the lorilynn of
quantitation of my method using percent
CB or M precision is I'll run a low-end
concentration curve so here you can see
that we am run a concentration curve
from 0 to 10 nanograms per mil for
drugging you can see down near the
bottom that the signal is not really
indistinguishable from noise of the
instrument you can't really see in the
signal higher than 0 so we would reckon
that the lower limit of quantitation is
probably somewhere in this area what we
would do is then make up a sample about
that concentration in order to determine
the between run precision of the sample
and then we would run it on a minimum of
20 times on 20 different days but at
this point if the end precision is too
high you can increase the concentration
of the sample and start the study again
if the CV is low and you need better
sensitivity then you can always decrease
the concentration of the sample and
start again so in this example and we
made a sample with a concentration of
0.5 nanograms per mil and we ran out on
20 different days and the concentrations
that were obtained can be seen in this
table
so then what we do is take the mean of
these concentrations and so it ends up
being point four nine again point four
nine nine at guns per mil the center
deviation is zero point zero two and the
percent cv is calculated as four point
eight percent so in this case the lower
limit of quantitation could be say at
two point four nanograms per mil because
as a CV of four point eight percent and
that's within our acceptability criteria
of twenty percent
so I mentioned earlier that you can use
signal-to-noise for determination of
your lower limb of quantitation and
that's shown on this slide so you can do
this in the mass spec software
essentially what you do is tell the
instrument what's the signal and in this
case it's the peak and what's the noise
which is the baseline here and it will
calculate the signal-to-noise ratio so
for this sample of drug eggs at 10
nanograms per mil the signal-to-noise
ratio was 136 to 1 as you mentioned
earlier the minimum signal-to-noise
ratio that you're hoping to achieve for
your limit or limit of quantitation
sample would be 20 to 1 so obviously we
would know that we could go to a lower
concentration for a lower limit of
quantitation here the one thing about
signal-to-noise ratios is that it's very
subjective utility instrument where the
signal is and were the noises and of
course you could pick noise that's
really flat as opposed to you know bumpy
and it's going to give you a higher
signal so and I'm more of a fan of
determining the imprecision in using the
in running the sample 20 times then
using the signal-to-noise
so in order to determine linearity and
we have to carry out this experiment and
every matrix that will be amusing and
obviously for every analyte - so the
linearity is the ability of the mass
spect method to provide counts per
second values that are directly
proportional to the concentration of the
analyte and so it's recommended that you
don't use serial dilutions to create
your material for linearity experiments
and that's because if you make a mistake
in one of them then it can even a small
mistake can create a large bias and then
if you zero deletions you're
perpetuating that bias through all of
the different sample
in terms of accessibility criteria one
example is shown here hey which is using
a systematic allowable error of your
lower limit of quantitation
concentration or 10% whichever is larger
you also have to be remind that the
accuracy or the recovery of your a
linearity material should be between 80
and 120 percent
it's best practice to use a minimum of
five nonzero points and five replicates
to determine the linearity of your
method and it's common to use one over X
weighting and for linearity and that M
helps to maintain the accuracy of the
law concentration end of your
calibration curve
and so in our laboratory we usually
evaluate linearity by running our
calibrators
so here you can see an example and where
you have the assigned concentration of
the calibrators and then three
replicates the measure concentrations of
three replicates and we have to set our
acceptability criteria so here we use
point four nine nanograms per mil which
is our lower limit of quantitation or
10%
and so if we plot this and with the
assigned concentrations against the
measured concentrations of these two
replicates of the calibrators we can see
that they they look pretty linear and on
the scatter plot we can also see that
the error was calculated is 0.42
nanograms per mil or 2.1 percent and
that's determined to be linear within in
the acceptability criteria that we set
forward in the beginning
so another linearity parameter that we
have to look at during our validation as
reportable range and that's the range of
concentrations that you're going to
report and so the reportable range
includes dilutions of high concentration
specimen or specimens with insufficient
sample volume or concentration of low
concentration specimen
and so these dilution our concentration
procedures must also be validated and to
do this we usually would spike five
different allah quarts of each plant
matrix that you're measuring with
specific concentrations of each analyte
and then we verify if the dilution or
the concentration in procedure works for
these alicorns so in our laboratory
right now we only have dilution
procedures we haven't ever needed to
concentrate any analytes and so in this
example we bite blank matrix with 5000
nanograms per ml of drugged eggs and
then we did a 1 to 4 deletion which
takes it down to 1200 and 1500 grams per
ml and the imprecision was less than 15%
and so we designated that as acceptable
so in order to delete the samples you
obviously need to fill you in and so you
could use analyte free matrix if you can
find that or some kind of surrogate
matrix for example water and its water
that we use mostly in our lab in the
accessibility criteria are that the
accuracy of the deletion or
concentration should be within plus or
minus 15% of the nominal analyte
concentration and the emphasis should be
less than 15% that's why we usually do
favor applicants
so the analytical measurement range is
essentially the range of concentrations
that can be measured directly without
doing a dilution or any type of
concentration for most in quantitative
mass spec methods this is going to be
from your lower limit of quantitation to
the concentration of the highest
calibrator and so in this example it
would be 0.49 to 2009 grams per mil for
drug a so we tend m to you we run our
calibrators with every run and so we
tend to have our AMR set up to the high
scrim the limit of quantitation up to
the highs calibrator but if you do want
to M
preventing addressee higher than your
highs calibrator then you would need to
do calibration verification every six
months to prove that you're still linear
to whatever concentration that you go up
to
so one important thing to look at with
my SPECT methods are a specificity or
interferences and these are the ability
of the mesfet method to measure solely
to an elite or analyte so that it's
designed to measure
and this includes the asite to both
exogenous and endogenous compounds on
the methods if you're measuring your
aniline serum you should also aim
determine the effect of hemolysis hrs
and YP mia on the method so for the
acceptability criteria the interference
of an exogenous or endogenous compound
should have a signal of less than 20% of
the lower limit of quantitation of
analyte that you're measuring and also
the interference should cause less than
a 15% bias and results
the jury method development em and my
spectrum aspect methods you should look
at in either baroque compounds and
isomeric compounds and then if you need
to you can alter the chromatography in
order to make sure that you're
specifically quantifying your analyte or
analytes of interest I thought it was
worth mentioning again here because you
should definitely document the compounds
that you tested in during your math math
avala Dacian paperwork these websites at
the bottom are useful to search for eyes
about calm pain such as endogenous
compounds or commonly used drugs and
their metabolites that could potentially
cause an interference in your mass spec
method and if you're going to do spiking
studies it's good to spike these
compounds into your blank matrix at very
high concentrations and higher than you
would find physiologically or
therapeutically just to make sure that
they don't affect your annecy so
essentially you would just take your
blank matrix like the compounds into
there
extract the samples as you would
normally and run them as unknowns on
your mass spec method and then you can
see if there's a peak or any kind of
interference other retention time of
your analyte of interest
this is just an example here in if you
have your drug-drug egg which has a
molecular weight 438 grams per mole and
you have an either bar that has the same
molecular weight but you need to trim
chromatographic Li separate them before
they enter the mass spec and compounds
that share common product lines to need
to be separated
as I mentioned earlier if you're going
to measure your analyte and serum or
plasma then you should evaluate
hemolysis hrs and laity Mia and how they
affect in your mass spect method it's
also really important to test different
collection tubes or collection devices
em on your mass spec method so if you're
only going to accept for example a red
top tube then you obviously have to make
sure that that doesn't cause any issues
and in your method and the tubes or this
collation tubes or devices can have an
effect on the analyte concentration
because it may absorb to the plastic or
the gel or it's also being shown that
some of the components of the plastic or
gel may interfere with mass spec methods
and so if you do see an interference
with a specific tube type or collection
device then you should probably not use
that tube recollection debates and that
should definitely be documented in your
validation paperwork
so an example of one of the experiments
we use for drug eggs is shown here in so
we spiked
Billy Rubin and lipids and hemoglobin
into blank matrix and you have to
remember and take care of the dilution
effect so if you're spiking in these
things into your blank matrix for the
negative sample you also have to spike
in mobile phase or water or something so
the aim the dilation is the same in both
a situation
and so then we after spiking these
compounds in we took the samples a
negative impulsive samples through the
extraction Li we would normally do and
then the calculated concentration is
shown here so for the beli Reuben
positive sample M the concentration was
3.8 percent higher than the negative
sample for the lipids there was no
difference and for the hemoglobin spite
samples there was a difference of about
1.4 percent so as you can see above ER
and acceptability criteria are that the
interference should cause the less than
15% bias and the results and all of
these situations passed the criteria so
they don't interfere at these
concentrations
and this is just an example of how a
collection tube can cause an
interference so here a drug example at
the top left hand side was collected and
one tube and as you can see there is one
peak with no interference however if you
collect the drug example in another tube
type you can see all these different
Peaks and the drug aches Peaks is kind
of formed by all these different pings
so as you can see here it is chromatic
graphically separated but if your method
didn't chromatographic Li separate these
interferences and you could definitely
miss quantify in the interference as
your drug eggs which is obviously a
problem so you know in this case since
you can chromatic you separate them you
could potentially accept the tube type
but it may make sense just to say that
the tube type is not acceptable
another weird way of adding a layer of
selectivity to your method is to use
iron ratio and this can be seen here on
this slide so if we have our transition
for drugging and for three eight two one
three eight this is the peak and then we
have another transition for three eight
to 100 and we get this peak if we take
that M
ratio of the peak area of the first
transition divided by the second
transition we get an iron ratio of one
if we look here on the right-hand side
with an unknown sample you have again
the same transition the four three eight
to one three eight at the top and the
four three two 100 at the bottom and if
you look at the iron ratio for this
sample is one point four five and
obviously that's very different to the
calibrator iron ratio and you normally
would expect that the iron ratios for
your samples and for your quality
control material are very similar to the
calibrators and here I don't know if you
can see but there is kind of a bump or a
hump on the side of this peak so that in
this case this is kind of an obvious
interference and in this situation I
would not report a result for the sample
I would send it to another laboratory to
be run on a different method but isn't
it always as obvious is that so iron
ratios can really help you to take the
unknown unknown and because no matter
how many interferences you test in your
method there's always the possibility
that there's something you haven't
totals and they can really affect the
quantitation of your analyte
I'm back when we were discussing the
lower limit of quantitation I said that
the iron ratios have to pass for those
samples and this is what I was talking
about
so matrix effects are iron suppression
is something that you hear talked about
a lot when you're talking about mass
spec and it really is kind of a mass
spec specific parameter that you have to
validate and so it's the influence of
components and a sample affecting the
ionization efficiency and therefore the
measurement of concentration of the
analyte in the sample and essentially it
says it the salt processes that no two
people are the same rate so no two
samples are the same look that are going
to enter the mass spec and so if you're
using reverse phase chromatography which
a lot of mass spec methods do you can
get iron suppression in very early in
your chromatographic run in caused by
polar components like salts and these
elute and the void volume and another
major source of iron suppression and
serum or plasma samples as phospholipids
and these are retained on the column and
can elute later in the run but they can
also be retained on the column and they
can elute anytime like later on in
different samples and your calorie
source so it's very important to
document the iron suppression in your
method
and so there's a couple different ways
of doing maths and so first we're going
to talk about the ways to quantify in
the matrix effect science oppression of
your muffin and so the best practice is
to evaluate 10 different metric samples
No 10 does sound a lot especially if
you're talking about endogenous analytes
where it's really hard even to find one
blank metric sample in but a regulatory
agency M has this and their criteria and
so it's probably best that we all do
this and so you basically take your ten
different matrix samples and extract
them and you take more fees and extract
that and Spike the analyte and at the
same concentration in each of these
eleven sample and again if you're using
different matrices and different
analytes you have to evaluate matrix
effect for each matrix and each analyte
and your method and this paper at the
bottom right hand side here it gives a
very good description of how to do these
experiments
so this is an example of some of the
experiments we did for drug eggs so we
have our mobile phase and then the ten
different matrices and this is the peak
area of drug a and the second column and
that's our column at the calculation so
we're basically comparing all our
matrices to the mobile phase because the
mobile phase really should have no
matrix of thing
and so if we have a hundred percent in
our percent matrix of X that means
there's no matrix effects if the number
is greater than 100% it means we have
iron enhancement and if it's less than
one hundred percent it means we have
iron suppression and our method and so
usually we can take the average of all
ten of these matrices and here you can
see that we have an average of one
hundred and four point seven percent
which means that we have about five
percent iron enhancement on average in
compared in this method in comparing the
different matrices
so another way to evaluate matrix
debates or ion suppression in your
method is to do it qualitatively and we
do this by using a post column and
fusion or a tea infusion of a standard
of your Annalee while you inject the
extracted samples and again you should
use 10 different matrix samples and this
basically permits detection of a
negative interference and so I'm no
artist as you can probably tell but this
is basically how you would say up your
instrument so you have your LC pumps you
have your extracted mobile phase and
extracted matrix samples and the auto
sampler you have your chromatography
column then you have a tea and this is
where you Tian your pure analyte
standard so you have a syringe pump
containing your pure analyte standard
and it's flowing at a constant rate into
the flow of the chromatography column or
the eluent for the chromatography column
and this is all going to enter the mass
spec
and so this is kind of an example of
what you would expect to see so again
you have constant infusion of your
analyte from the syringe pump and these
three examples here and example a this
is your mobile phase injection so as you
can imagine if you have constant
infusion of your analyte from the
syringe pump and there's no matrix
effects then you would have basically
sort of a flat signal of your analyte if
you inject serum has been extracted
using a liquid liquid extraction you can
see here that there's iron suppression
just before one minute of the
chromatography run and then it kind of
goes flat and then there's a little dip
here it just before five minutes and
it's kind of flagging so there's
definitely some matrix factor and
suppression in this method right around
just before one minute so obviously you
wouldn't want your analyte to look from
the column at that time because the
signal is going to be very suppressed
especially if you're looking em to get
you know high sensitivity from your
method and the third example is if you
use a protein precipitation method to
extract your serum and here you can see
that there's a few dips and the signal
indicating areas of iron suppression so
again you wouldn't want your analyte to
ill-lit from the column and any of these
areas and another thing that this shows
is that liquid extraction cleans up your
samples much better than protein
precipitation which is something we
probably all knew em anyway so this is a
way to a qualitatively see where areas
of iron suppression are in your method
another thing you could do is do the
same experiment with your internal
standard and it's the internal standard
signal dips where the analyte dips and
you can in it kind of shows that your
internal standard is kind of accounting
for in the in suppression that hits both
your internal Center on your Annalee you
can also do the same experiment for the
quantitative experiment with your
internal standard as well
and so shown on this later just some
references as far as matrix effects are
concerned
another thing that we should look at
during our method validation as
stability and that's somewhat difficult
to accomplish during validation you
should really test your Annalee and the
matrix at every condition that it might
encounter you can also do a literature
search in PubMed to see if anyone else
has already done it but they may not
have used the same matrix or the same
temperature that you're looking to in
story your analyte so it's not always
successful and you know if you think
about it if you make your own
calibrators then how do you know how
stable they are until you test them for
a long time but that's not really
something you're going to be able to
accomplish during validation so the
acceptability criteria for stability
studies are that it there should be a
less than 15% change from freshly
obtained or freshly extracted sample
except to the lower limit of
quantitation where a less than 20%
change is acceptable
so some of the conditions that we test
for in our laboratory are how long will
the samples be stored before analysis
and at what temperature if you have
already extracted the samples but your
mass spec goes down
how long can these samples be stored and
at what temperature or if your sample
needs to be run at a later date again
how long can it be stored in a ward
temperature and another thing to
consider is freeze thaw stability so if
you have calibrators and you have you
know a milliliter but you only need to
use 50 microliters for each run can you
freeze thaw the calibrators or do you
have to install them one time and just
use them and keep them in the
refrigerator and you can also think
about this for your quality control
samples and your aim human sample
this is an example of one of our
stability experiments of what we did
here was take ten patient samples and we
extracted them fresh and ran them on the
instrument him on 10 30 2017 and these
are the concentrations that we got we
then took these extracted samples and
stored them at four degrees C for one
week and then we re injected these
samples a week later and these are the
concentrations that we've got here in
column three and then in column four we
calculated the percent recovery and by
taking the result from 1106 dividing it
by the result from 1030 and multiplying
by 100 and as you can see the lowest
recovery that we have here is 88% and so
that's within the stability a the
acceptability criteria of less than 15%
and so it was determined that the
samples for drug X are stable for one
week at four degrees C once you've been
extracted
so your LC ms/ms system is a continuous
floor system and so there is the
potential for high concentration samples
to carry over into the next sample in
the accessibility criteria for carryover
studies are that it should not
significantly impact the bias or the
precision of the method so in our
laboratory we use 1% as criteria for
acceptability for carryover so an
example experiment that you could use
here is to extract 3 low concentration
samples then extract a very high
concentration sample then extract 3 more
low concentration samples and run them
in that order and so what you would do
is compare the low concentration samples
that were injected before versus
injected after the high concentration
sample
and this is an example of the experiment
for drug X so we have our three low
concentration samples and when we
injected them before the high
concentration sample we got
concentrations of twelve point two
eleven point seven and eleven point five
so the average was eleven point eight we
then injected the high concentration
sample which was ten thousand nano grams
per mil and then we ran three low
concentration samples after the high
concentration sample and so these
concentrations of the wall samples chemo
is twelve point eight eleven point eight
and eleven point seven for an average of
twelve point one nanograms per mil but
then we can calculate the percent carry
over by taking the average concentration
after minus the average concentration of
the low samples before dividing up by
the concentration of the high sample and
multiplying by a hundred and in this
case we get carryover of about point
zero three percent which is within our
criteria of one percent
the reference intervals are something
and that we have to think about
especially for endogenous analytes and
again these are somewhat difficult
accomplished to accomplish in dependent
on the analyte if you want to establish
reference interval of your own then it
requires a minimum of 120 normal samples
and another way to do is to verify an
establish reference interval for your
population and in that case it would
require a minimum of 20 normal samples
and their acceptability criteria to
verify and establish reference interval
is that a maximum of two samples could
be out with that reference interval and
one thing to remember is that if you
have gender specific or age specific
reference intervals then you have to
verify in each one so you would need 20
samples for each in a population if
you're looking at exogenous non
therapeutic compounds and the reference
interval would be negative or non
present and then for exogenous
therapeutic compounds if therapeutic
ranges are already established then they
can be found in the literature or
potentially in the package answer of the
drug them another option is also am if
you can to communicate with pharmacists
in your institution and they can
probably help guide you in the right
direction
validation parameters that we have to
think about or the maximum batch size
that you're going to run so if you're
running in files how many samples can
you have in one run and or you know if
you're running in plates you can also
document the extraction recoveries so
you can spike your sample and take it
all the way through in extraction and
then bake a sample after it's been
extracted to see and compare the
difference between em before and after
to see how much of your analyte you
recover or you basically how much of
your analyte you lose during the
extraction process and you can look at
retention time stability
and this is helpful too if you change
columns to make sure that the retention
time is stable you can look at the slope
of your calibration curve if proficiency
testing samples are available then you
can run them and see how you can pair
you can compare and you if you're going
to validate your method on two different
instruments and you have to do between
instrument correlation as well as a full
validation on both instruments you can
also document a lots a lot variability
and mobile phase so you can make up
different batches of mobile phase and
have different people make them up and
then test samples that have already been
run and then this way you can come up
with criteria for acceptability once you
actually go live with your method
there's probably other parameters in
that I'm forgetting but this is a good
list another thing that you want to do
is set up your acceptability criteria
for your run so once you're actually
live with your muffin and what has to
happen or what has to be true before you
will actually report results and so you
can use retention time of your analyte
and internal standards you can make sure
they match we're using normally
isotopically labeled internal standards
so the retention time of Annalee and the
internal standard should be the same and
you can make sure there's no interfering
Peaks in the method you can look at the
calibrator recover your accuracy and you
can set criteria is 80 to 120 percent
recovery you can set the r-squared of
your calibration curve to be greater
than 0.99 your quality control material
has to be in range so you have to have
determined what the range is and then it
has to be in range before you can report
results
the iron ratios of your unknowns and of
your quality control material should be
within plus or minus 20% of the
calibrators and the same run or the same
batch and also and you should monitor
your internal standard peak areas and
they should be consistent in between all
of the samples too so an example of
criteria criteria that you could use is
that peak internal center peak areas and
your skim and sample should be plus or
minus within plus or minus 2 SD of that
find in your calibrators and these are
all things that you can use your
validation Christ a data to determine
right so you see how your assay performs
during validation and you use that to
say criteria for when you go live
because you want to be able to catch
issues but you also don't want to feel
every single run that you have so it's
really important to do a really good
validation very in-depth and over a
significant period of time so that you
know how your assay performs on its best
day and on its worst day
so once you've actually going live with
your method you put all this validation
to work you've gone live with your
method there's things that you should do
in terms of post validation monitoring
to ensure that your instrument is
performing that your a/c is performing
know that you're running it live and so
things that you can use the monitor
instrument performance are your system
suitability sample and we'll get to that
in a minute in order to monitor sample
analysis performance you're using your
quality control materials with every run
and you can use your internal standard
peak areas across your run as well in
terms of looking at your assay
performance over time you're going to do
proficiency testing you could do
accuracy assessments using a certified
reference material if that's available
for your analyte and you should do a lot
to look validation of your mobile phases
your calibrators your quality controls
your column and also if you do run your
method on different instruments and you
should do instrument comparisons every
six months make sure that they're still
running the same way
you should also obviously do instrument
maintenance and this really depends on
your manufacturer recommendations your
personal experience also how much you
actually run your instrument so right
now for example we clean the front end
of our instrument once a month but if we
were to increase the volume of samples
that we run or if we were to run in
samples that weren't extracted so well
so perhaps samples that we did in just a
protein precipitation for them we may
have to consider cleaning the front end
of the instrument more often we do have
the manufacturer come in and do a
periodic maintenance every six months as
well
so what's your system suitability sample
so it's essentially a non extracted
sample it does not go through sample
preparation and so this is really just a
test of your instrument it's not a test
of your sample prep process it's a test
of your instrument on the day that
you're running and some different
concentration situations are that you
should have it near the lower limit of
quantitation to evaluate your instrument
sensitivity you could have it in the
middle of your analytical measurement
range or near a medical decision point
so basically what you do is prepare a
large batch of this so it's just your
analyte spiked into M for example
methanol and water or something like
that and you have to store it
according to stability standards so if
you've a m-- validated stability then
you know how to store it you essentially
want to run this with some suitability
sample daily before you do any analysis
to make sure that your instrument is
performing the way it should do after
any instrument maintenance or a power
outage or any kind of break in vacuum of
the instrument and also AM after you've
had periodic maintenance like tuning and
calibration has been in carried out
because you're basically want to make
sure that the instrument is performing
the way that you know it should
and so others that you can monitor for
the system suitability sample or a shift
in retention time this could be gradual
or sudden aim and there's a number of
different reasons that the retention
time could shift and they're seen here
it could be the call and degrading it
could be that your LC buffers are
evaporating or there's been some kind of
pH change could be that your LC pumps in
are not mixing properly or there's a
leak somewhere you can also look at the
peak shape of your system suitability
samples so in is there any tailing or
fronting or is a PK symmetric and again
this could be and the kisses that
there's something wrong with your column
or your buffers or your mass spec itself
and again if there's any additional
Peaks observed that are not usually
observed there could be a problem also
if there's a drop and intensity of the
peak free system suitability sample it
could be due to your mass spec needing
clean again changes in your buffers or
potentially something wrong with the
injector on your system and it could be
clogged or the loop typical daemon also
could end the keep columns excitation
there's really important to monitor in
system soot valleys example every time
you run it into document what's find em
and so then you could potentially go
back to and see if over time there has
been a gradual decrease in and the peak
intensity so is that your instrument
getting dirty or is the actual system
suitability sample not stable
so now that you've done all this hard
work it's time to write your validation
summary report so usually in the lives
of writers signs often kind of a
one-page summary but that's not really
very informative so it's helpful to put
together and I like a validation summary
that summarizes the results for each
experiment that we've just discussed and
this is basically than me in the
sandwich and you can also aim at the
bottom of the sheet of paper and put the
electronic file location that's very
useful because then you can go back and
find it
much more quickly if there was any
failures and during the method
development and as a validation process
and whether you fix them then put that
in there don't emit data that reveals
some kind of true problem that you fixed
and also include corrective actions so
if you find an error that could have
clinical significance for example some
kind of interference a very high
concentration of a drug causes the iron
ratio to fail write that in there and
then you would include a calming about
the interference and the validation
report
so now that we've validated our assay
this could be like our one-page summary
and so for drug eggs or accuracy was
acceptable we had Amin bias of six
percent it compared to another lab our
lower limit of quantitation is 0.4
nanograms per mil analytical measurement
range is 0.49 to 2009 mms per mil we had
acceptable imprecision both the within
day and between day and we had about 5%
a Mayan enhancement as far as matrix
effects are concerned
so lastly just some advice um I have
done this for a few asses now and every
time I do something silly and and one
thing that I did that was really silly
was in do most of the validation myself
for one I see and that came back to bait
me as soon as we went life and we had
multiple technologists so during the
validation you want to throw in every
single type of change in condition that
you can think of so you want to have
multiple technologists you want to have
multiple mobile fees law it's made by
multiple different people if you can
it's good to try different column words
obviously columns are fairly expensive
that may or may not be possible you
definitely want to carry out normal
instrument maintenance we were in the
middle of the validate nan dasi and we
had our preventive maintenance done and
when after the engineer left our a/c did
not work at all so it's good to know
these things
editing em you want to test on sunny
days and rainy days and of course that's
kind of a joke but it's true anything
that could possibly affect your a/c you
want to throw at them during method
validation so that when you're actually
live with it there's less chance of
these things happening that could affect
the performance of your a/c and lastly
document document document and our if
it's not written down it never happened
so document every little thing and this
again could be during validation this
could be afterwards you know in any
troubleshooting that you that you do
write it down write down what the
problem was write down what you did to
fix it so that people can go back and
refer to it in case the same problem
happens again
in conclusion / dr. Russell grant
validation as a risk based exercise the
more work you put into validation the
less risk you have of your method
feeling afterwards
I would just like to quickly acknowledge
some people who helped put this
presentation together dr. Judith thorn
dr. Josh Hayden dr. Julie Botello and
then everybody at UCSF clinical
laboratories who I work with and with
that I would like to
thank you for your attention and I would
be happy to take any questions
Thank You dr. French for your
presentation quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. French will answer as many questions
as time permits okay first question is
for pre validation do you need to use
your finalized calibrators and quality
control so not necessarily and I think I
mentioned earlier that in I often will
make my own calibrators and during pre
validation just to test the method and
just to make sure that they work so you
know if you have already purchased
calibrators and then you find out that
your a/c isn't linear in to the
concentration of the highest
concentration and you know that wouldn't
that would be terrible I know and I
would say it's probably better to test
your system first to see what linearity
you can achieve to make sure that your
calibrators cover the linearity that you
want em and then decide when your your
quality control sample should be and and
then potentially order them or make them
after you've sort of done your pre
validation so once you're more am happy
with the exact measurement range that
you're going to use thank you your next
one is can you do between run precision
experiments over five days for
replicates per gay yes so this is this
is a common question and you know you
can I I think the requirement as 20
points em I just wouldn't recommend it
and the reason for that is you know like
I can it was drill in home at the end
you really want to throw as many
different em things that your method as
you possibly can and if you only
validate and precision over five days
and you do four replicates you're not
really getting the variation of
different days different weeks different
people right i mean i guess you could
get different people in over five days
and you know again it's a risk based
exercise the more
or the more useful asset the the more
chance you have of seeing it fail at
this point as opposed to later on and so
I just think you'd get a better idea of
how your method is going to perform when
you run it over more days and the other
thing to remember is you have a lot of
experiments to do during your validation
you have patient samples to run you know
you have in your precision samples you
have carryover you have reportable range
you have a lot of studies so really you
are going to do a lot of runs and so
it's not really an added hardship to do
precision experiments over more more
days than just five days at four
replicates per day thank you
what material do you use for the
hemolysis victress and leukemia
experiments so that's a good question
and it's a little controversial and for
for like Kimia because we we usually do
use intra lipid so you can by enjoy
lipid it's what people use for TPN and
and hospitals or patients that can eat
they get Intrepid intravenously um it's
not really a good capitulation of what
you will find in LA PM example but it's
kind of a surrogate so we use intro
lipid for YP Mia experiments so we just
in measure the lipids in that using our
chemistry analyzer and then get the
concentration and then we can figure out
a what we need to add to our samples are
spiking samples and for Atreus we
actually have been using Cal
verification material calibration
verification material just to spike it
contains bilirubin to spike in our
samples with and for hemolysis what we
actually do in life red blood cells and
they measure the in measure the
haemoglobin and then again spike into
our samples using the aim the lysed red
blood cell
thank we have time for one more question
how do you find blank matrix for ion
suppression experiments of endogenous
analytes yes oh that's a that's a really
good question M you can use stripped
matrix so and you can buy double
charcoal stripped matrix and to do these
experiments forever in with the
regulatory requirement of 10 different
matrices that makes it kind of difficult
so what we tend to try and do is look
for patient samples that either have a
really low concentration or like
undetectable concentration which can be
very difficult but we do get them and
then we can use the infraspinatus I mean
for the iron suppression studies to
spike in your analyte at certain
concentration the other thing you can do
is in run is use patient samples and run
them straight first of all to get the
actual concentration of your analyte and
then when you add your analyte on top a
certain concentration then you can just
sort of subtract the concentration in
that you find when you run it straight
before you were denying special
experiments so we just did this for
estradiol M and so we found or we
thought about picking samples that were
kind of potentially low estradiol
concentrations so in that case we look
for male I don't nail samples and then
for some pediatric samples and we ran
them straight first so that we got like
a baseline concentration and then we in
spite on top in a known concentration
and then we just subtract to the peak
area over there in and so that's you
don't necessarily have to use blank
matrix and I feel more comfortable using
real patient matrix rather than the in
the double charcoal strip matrix because
it definitely is a better indicator of
what's going to happen with your real
patient sample
I would like to once again to thank dr.
French for her presentation do you have
any final comments no just thank you
thanks again for the invitation and I
don't know if the slightest elope has my
email address on it if anyone has any
further questions then they can feel
free to email me okay thank you I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our educational
sponsor Agilent for today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through March 2019 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye